salam aleikum is my esteban one am inn
méxico
eso significa hola me llamo esteban y
soy de mexico
esa frase me ha servido para mucho más
que presentarme en distintos puntos de
mi vida hace cerca de dos años cuando
terminaba mi doctorado se presentaba en
frente a mi algunas oportunidades de
trabajo hacer un posdoctorado tener una
posición de investigador de tiempo
completo o crear una empresa en arabia
saudita y bueno escogí la última la
verdad es que esta opción representaba
por mucho la más arriesgada pero también
representaba para mí algo mucho más
profundo representaba la oportunidad de
ser completamente libre en esta vida o
al menos lo más cercano a eso y déjenme
explicarles de qué a qué me refiero con
esta libertad por un lado me refiero a
la libertad de reinventarse a uno mismo
de ser la mejor versión de ti mismo esa
versión que se despierta temprano todos
los días que lee que aprende cosas
nuevas constantemente que planea y sobre
todo
que las cosas sucedan y por otro lado la
libertad de generar un cambio positivo
en tu entorno que en mi caso es arabia
saudita
y por qué hablo de estas libertades
porque estas libertades permiten algo
vital en toda sociedad permiten la
innovación que es innovar innovar no es
necesariamente estar en un laboratorio
desarrollando tecnología o haciendo
investigación para crear un nuevo
conocimiento innovar es sencillamente
hacer algo de una manera mejor y eso
está al alcance de todos
en sadismo hacemos tecnología y déjeme
mostrar algunas una foto de lo que yo
creo es nuestra mayor innovación como
empresa
nuestro equipo de trabajo parte de
nuestro equipo de trabajo en arabia
saudita consta de gente de cuatro
continentes distintos diferentes
nacionalidades religiones y creencias
en resumen distintas visiones del mundo
pero todos trabajando por un bien común
alcanzar esto requiere mucho esfuerzo y
sobre todo requiere entender las
diferencias del prójimo saber que esas
diferencias más allá de ser un obstáculo
pueden enriquecerse
y eso es algo muy importante y eso es
parte de la innovación
para poder llegar y para poder obtener o
entender estas diferencias se deben
experimentar las
hace no mucho tuvimos la oportunidad de
hablar con un general del ejército de
arabia saudita y presentar nuestra
tecnología la verdad es que era una de
nuestras primeras reuniones de este tipo
estábamos bastante nerviosos y yo
acompañé a mis socios como apoyo porque
mi nivel de árabe todavía no es
suficiente para presentar en una en una
junta de este nivel
el general la verdad es que se
impresionó por nuestra tecnología pero
asimismo se impresionó cuando tuve la
oportunidad de hablar con él y decirle
una frase similar con la que inicia esta
charla él se interesó demasiado en saber
cómo un mexicano había viajado tanto
había llegado a su país había creado una
empresa y ahora le estaba hablando en
árabe
y recuerdo que me dijo dos cosas la
primera fue en la segunda junta
mejora tu árabe y la segunda cosa fue
cásate con una saudí para que
perfecciones tu árabe yo la verdad es
que solo le hice caso en la primera
y bueno los que saben de ventas saben
que muchas veces necesitas al menos tres
juntas para lograr el trato y bueno ya
teníamos la segunda en otra ocasión nos
tocó ir con un presidente municipal en
arabia saudita y el protocolo es te
reúnes tienes la junta de trabajo y
luego compartes una comida con ellos en
esa región de arabia la comida típica es
arroz y cordero
se come en el suelo y se come con las
manos bueno con una mano con la mano
derecha y yo siendo zurdo y además
tienen una fijación por comer con los
cubiertos se podrán imaginar el reto que
eso representaba para mí lo intente con
mi poco porque la mitad del arroz se me
caía sin embargo en aproximadamente un
mes vamos a instalar un proyecto en esa
ciudad
y lo que estas historias reflejan es que
hay que tener empatía empatía con el
prójimo
porque porque cuando tú tienes empatía
le demuestras al prójimo que te importa
que te importa entender esas diferencias
y cuando alguien te importa esa persona
confía en ti y cuando confía en ti pues
puede darte un proyecto para poner una
tecnología en tu ciudad
ahora esta multiculturalidad de nuestro
equipo no sólo se refleja en esto
también podemos hacer cambios positivos
en la sociedad como dato en sadim el 45%
de nuestro personal es femenino y quizás
sí le digo este número a alguien en
suecia pues no le cause mucha impresión
pero en arabia saudita las empresas en
promedio tienen entre un 20 y un 25 por
ciento de personal femenino este
porcentaje tan bajo es reflejo de los
retos que representa para una mujer el
unirse al área laboral de acuerdo al
contexto en el que haya crecido por
ejemplo nosotros hemos tenido
situaciones donde las mujeres renuncian
por el simple hecho de que alguien la
expresión o familia o la sociedad y eso
mejorar eso es un reto que hemos
decidido enfrentar como empresa también
trabajamos mucho en el empoderamiento de
jóvenes mujeres y hombres que se
conviertan en líderes en distintas áreas
desde el desarrollo de tecnología hasta
el área administrativa todos estos
cambios o innovaciones sociales se
entienden y se reflejan en un contexto
local en este caso arabia sin embargo
deben ser llevadas a un contexto global
tuve la oportunidad de presentar la
empresa en una conferencia internacional
a un político de alto nivel y éste se
impresionó por dos cosas por la
multiculturalidad de nuestro equipo y
por como gente con visión con visiones
distintas del mundo estaban trabajando
por metas en común y para mí fue una
gran satisfacción el demostrarle con el
ejemplo a un tomador de decisión del
mundo que la sinergia entre culturas es
posible y no sólo es posible es
necesaria
quizás estarán pensando bueno todo esto
suena muy bonito pero qué hay de las
facturas que hay de los pagos para la
renta los sueldos de una empresa y claro
todo esto es cierto de hecho como
emprendedores tenemos el compromiso y la
responsabilidad de que nuestras empresas
funcionen de que las cuentas salgan pero
no podemos conformarnos con eso debemos
ir más allá debemos innovar estoy
convencido que los emprendedores tenemos
la oportunidad única de causar una
verdadera revolución social cuestionar
el statu quo detonar el sistema
tradicional que muchas veces es tan
injusto y de generar riqueza más allá
del dinero toda empresa innovadora en el
mundo debe convertirse en un catalizador
de cambios positivos para su entorno
estoy convencido que desde arabia
estambul hoy hermosa donde nos
encontremos
debemos aprovechar los recursos que
tenemos a nuestro alrededor
cooperar y entre todos y a través de una
innovación constante causar una
verdadera revolución social y ucrania si
leen muchas gracias
[Aplausos]